so i've seen all of season two uh it is
fantastic
fans are gonna love it uh i'm always
curious what you're allowed to say so i
hate asking the generic thing but what
are you allowed to say about season two
yeah no worries i mean i think we could
talk about you know the uh depending on
on what the interview might air is uh is
this notion of the bigger themes of the
show this season which i think it really
season two talks about you know broadly
speaking about identity everyone's
different struggle with identity uh but
specifically with issues topical issues
like cancer culture issues of race you
know uh covet plays an enormous part in
the season
uh and politics play play a considerable
amount of part the 2020 election um so
all of those things uh definitely uh
come into play and we pick up about six
months where we left off the end of
season one where alex has essentially
blown up the network and we have a
reconfiguring of of the power positions
in season two at uba we have a new head
ahead of a new uh news division in
stella bach and we and corey has become
the uh the head of the network
essentially so
um so those are like sort of the broad
strokes um yeah that's that's
essentially
about as much as i could say by the way
that was very good uh it's almost like
you've done it before
it's my first interview
so uh do you view corey as a good person
a bad person or does it depend on the
day of the week you know that's a
phenomenal question and that's wha and
that you're asking that question tells
me how good the writing is uh and not
not only just obviously the way billy
has interpreted that role which is
phenomenal uh but it starts with what's
on the page as we all know and when you
have writers like carrie aaron who i had
the privilege to work with on bates
motel
you're guaranteed a role that people are
going to love and hate at different
times you know she did that with norma
bates she did it certainly with my
character with norman bates you know on
bates motel and she does it with just
about every role on the show um except
maybe mine uh yanko there's a handful of
us that that are spared a lot of that
sort of uh
that i mean not not the darkness but
that sort of uh you know the the i don't
know the the ill will from the public
maybe
uh yeah so without getting into exact
specifics um yanko is dealing with the
cancel culture yeah
this this season um and he has an
interesting without getting specific he
has an interesting reaction to certain
things that are asked of him
yes you actually agree with the way
yanko reacts or did you sort of do you
know what i mean
i i fully know what you mean and i am
fully fully on yanko's camp on this
particular issue uh i think you know we
can say some stuff you know uh on the
issue
he says something on air
uh flippantly that is construed by one
person on twitter as uh racially
insensitive and that person subsequently
launches a campaign
to to uh to essentially destroy him you
know um
and
and then the interesting thing is the
the head of the news division the new
head
sides with the campaign over yanko uh
and and i think she has sort of
preconceived ideas of yanko because he
made some flippant remark about politics
that she pegged him as a certain way and
she's put two and two together in in her
mind and figured this guy is a racially
insensitive guy uh and and i'm gonna i'm
gonna have him do exactly what the
public wants him to do and i won't have
his back until he does he does
everything that that i ask of him so he
goes on this sort of the beginning of an
apology tour uh and i love what the
writers basically said about this notion
of cancel culture which is
you know once you go down that path you
know
what when is it enough when is apology
an apology enough you know uh when the
goalposts keep moving
and it is a common on our times it is
common on the insidious nature
of cancer culture and and the drawbacks
from that you know where it's not just
you're criticizing someone you're
actually trying to destroy them
yeah the the other thing is that uh and
the way i look at it when you're on a
morning show and you are live
every day and asking to talk
at some point you're gonna mess up with
what you say like you're gonna say
something that is not right and you know
you know what i mean i i know exactly
what you mean and it's a beautiful point
you're absolutely right when you're so
exposed when it's live
you're going to say something off the
cuff it's going to offend somebody um
yeah it's bound to happen we've gone to
a point now where comedians are very
open so many of them about the fact that
they've had to you know monitor
themselves when they do a set to the
point where they've watered down every
single joke for fear of being canceled i
mean david spake i think i just read an
article who's talking about that very
same issue and it is i mean jerry
seinfeld's spoken about it so many of
them have spoken about it that uh it
it's it's a real shame it's a comment on
our times that we're not allowed to
offend
god forbid we offend it i need any turn
you know so when we don't offend we also
don't we don't also don't risk making
people people laugh or think differently
i think you i think certain comedians uh
that are at a certain level
uh can get away with whatever the hell
they're going to say
because they're protected by just their
audience if you will it's not very yes
but you have to reach a certain level to
get to where you're protected yeah don
rickles would get away with anything you
know back in the day and there's certain
comedians nowadays
there you go
hey
that is my counterpart i feel like yanko
gets no respect either absolutely you
know this is
you're absolutely right there's there
are people who have a built-in audience
that whether they have their own podcast
you know their own that they're not
beholden to uh you know a corporation
having to censor them in any way uh
they're they're beholden to their
subscribers you know and and that's
enough you know and thank god for that
um because uh you know they're not uh
having to do absurd things you know to
to defend themselves where they don't
need to defend themselves and obviously
there's times when people do need to
defend themselves and there is a place
for it but putting all that power in the
hands of someone uh who's anonymously
typing on a keyboard is a dangerous
thing
my last question for you i love learning
about the behind the scenes of the
making of series movies whatever what do
you think might surprise people to learn
about the making of the morning show
well i mean i think uh well one thing is
that we've shot this entire season in
los angeles you know we uh
you know i
i don't know if that's something i
should say because then people are going
to start looking for it but that is a
credit to our incredible uh you know
special effects department yeah and
production design department
unbelievable what they accomplished uh
you know on those sets on you know
outside making la look like new york
times square is nothing short of
extraordinary i was blown away when i
saw it uh so that's extraordinary um
and i think the the groundbreaking thing
i think at the time is that we didn't
know how we're gonna come back and when
we were gonna come back because the
pandemic was still pretty much in full
swing when we started shooting resume
shooting and it's thanks to apple and
the protocols and all the research they
did through these epidemiologists that
they that they hired for the show that
we were able to shoot without any real
interruption the entire second season
when we went back and that was
extraordinary too on that note i got to
stop i'm just going to say congrats on a
great season thank you so much for
talking with me oh it's my pleasure
thank you so much